>> Mark Dimunation: I'm Mark
Dimunation, and I'm Chief
of the Rare Book Division.
And we're very happy to have
here today the young Russell
Maret [laughter], an
appellation that he earned many,
many years ago back
in the Eisenhower
administration when I -- No.
Russell, but I have known
Russell for a very long time.
And when he came in,
he was a young printer
and had been just starting up.
Much of I have, I think
his oldest production now,
which is '96, 1996,
I think, right?
>> Ninety-four.
>> Mark Dimunation: Ninety-four.
I think I do.
And has been producing
consistently since then.
What has happened with
Russell is that he's emerged
from being a kind of
spunky, at the edge,
always pushing himself sort of
printer to emerge to become one
of the greatest, certainly one
of the most innovative and --
What was the third one you
wanted me to say [laughter]?
Genre-breaking.
John, you knew you were going
to pay for that, didn't you?
Genre-breaking printers
of his generation.
I actually sincerely mean that.
And anyone who knows his work,
especially the flow of his work
over time, would agree.
He's a great friend
to this institution.
We are the home of much
of his archival material,
which means people in Washington
have the opportunity not only
to look at his book, but
also understand the process
of this innovative, grand,
genre-breaking printer,
and understand the meaning
behind many of his books.
Today, for a change,
he's going back in time.
And if there's anything
that Russell can do,
it's he can tell a story.
And there are many,
many of story
from Russell's publications
because one
of the things he does typically
in publication is try something
that's utterly impossible.
And those of us who've
been on the phone with him
when he's printing where
you say, you're running it
through 17 times, all
blue, I don't understand,
you'll get a notion of
that from Russell's talk.
So we're really thrilled to
have my good friend Russell
here today.
So please welcome him.
[ Applause ]
>> Russell Maret: Thank you.
Yeah. Yeah, I had this nice,
smooth entrance planned,
but you messed it up.
Anyway, you know, DC has a real
warm place in my heart my, well,
this is going to sound weird,
but because the two largest
collections of my work are here.
That's not why it
has the warm spot.
It's because those collections
were built by two people,
Al Mears and Mark Dimunation,
who have become very dear
and close friends of mine.
And the reason that we're here
today is because Al Mears,
who is the only person who
has a complete collection
of my published work, has
decided to sell his copy
of the first book I published,
"Meditation on Saviors,"
to the library, which
is the only book
of mine they do not have.
And for any collector
in the room,
you'll understand how
momentous a gesture that is
for a collector to
relinquish their top position.
And so, I just want to thank Al.
[ Applause ]
So I'm sure it's bittersweet.
It is for both of us.
But in thinking about when
I say he's the only person
who has a complete collection,
what I mean by that is,
I've never owned a copy of
"Meditation on Saviors."
And the process of making
it was so excruciating,
both psychologically
and technically,
that I've tried ever
since to forget it.
But in thinking about this
gesture of the book moving here,
I realize that the things
that made it so difficult,
technically at least, rather
than me having learned from them
and stopped using that
as a working method,
the process by which I came
to the design and making
of "Meditation on Saviors"
is the process that I employ
in almost all the
work I've made since,
which is why I get
those weird phone calls.
You're doing what?
So anyway, so I decided that
it would be fun to look back
at some projects through
that lens of the sort
of completely impractical
decision that ends
up bringing me into new
ground or whatever in my work.
And so, the story starts
when I looked like this.
And when I was 18 years old,
I got on a train in New York
for San Francisco to study
poetry at the New College
of California, now defunct.
And shortly after arriving,
I walked into a print shop
that was in the basement and
had my first profound experience
of love at first sight.
And it was literally the only
thing I'd ever wanted to do,
and I've done it for
the 30 years since then.
And shortly after that
experience, I met Peter Koch,
great printer in the Bay
Area, who was teaching
at New College for
that one year.
And I started apprenticing
in his studio.
And at the time, he also got
me a gig living and working
at the Press in Tuscany Alley,
which was a storied
California private press.
And between the two of those,
I really had this feeling
that I was being sort of
inculcated into the tradition
of the California private press.
And for that movement,
there's no greater barterer
than Robinson Jeffers,
that he is seen here
in the iconic photograph
by Edward Weston, you know,
with open collar,
in front of rock.
You know, he's a man.
He's a man.
And for those of you who don't
know Robinson Jeffers, you know,
he and his wife,
Una, moved to Carmel
when it was a very
different place.
Clint Eastwood didn't
live there.
And he built them a house
out of granite and cypress
from the Carmel headlands
called Tor House and Hawk Tower.
And this all became part of his
sort of myth as this rugged,
misanthropic poet who like
sat in his tower and looked
at the sea with his
back to humanity.
And he wrote a lot of things.
My favorite line from "Hurt
Hawks" is, "I'd sooner,
except the penalties,
kill a man than a hawk."
You know, he wrote
things like that.
And the editions of his
work that are published
by private press printers tend
to sort of emphasize that aspect
of him, that sort
of manly quality.
This is Peter Koch's
"Point Lobos."
The slide doesn't give
a sense of its scale,
but two people could eat dinner
comfortably off of this book.
It's huge and massive.
And it clearly references
the most famous edition
of Robinson Jeffers' poetry,
William Everson's "Granite
and Cypress," which is a
remarkable typographic work
that's housed in, I think
now looking back on it as,
a kind of gimmicky
cypress and granite box.
The book itself, the printed
book is really remarkable.
But this is how the private
press movement had traditionally
interpreted Robinson
Jeffers' work.
And however much I might have
thought of myself, like to think
of myself as being like Robinson
Jeffers, I'm really not.
And I just chose this
picture for two reasons: one,
it's me with my collar
open in front of rock.
The other is that, you
can't see it very well,
but I'm wearing a striped,
short-sleeve shirt,
which is the shirt that I
wore the first time I came
to meet Mark Dimunation here.
>> Probably your only shirt.
>> Russell Maret: Probably
my only shirt, yeah, yeah.
I spent it all on paper.
But anyway, so I
finished my apprenticeship
or ended my apprenticeship in
California and went on to work
at Firefly Press in Boston for
a bit and then found my way back
to New York to start a press.
And I knew I wanted
to make books,
but it was really hard
figuring out what book to make.
And in the process, I sort
of met this illustrator,
Murray Tinkelman, who somehow
convinced me to do a book
about the Brooklyn Dodgers.
And, at some point,
I became keenly aware
that I didn't want my first
book to be about a subject
for which I didn't
care, which is baseball.
And so, I started talking with
this artist, Paul Maloney,
in California, and we
came up with the idea
of maybe doing a Jeffers'
book with some poems
and his illustrations.
And at the time, I thought it
would be very much in that vein
of the California, you
know, the big, chunky book.
But in the meantime, I wrote a
poem for a girlfriend of mine
at the time and decided
to print it as a book.
And she had lived in Japan.
And so, I came up with this idea
of making a book that would be
like a Japanese screen,
where I'd make these
little wood screens,
stretch the printed
pages over the front,
and then put a decorative
paper on the back.
And it would collapse and
open up and everything.
So I set to work.
I printed the poem.
I built my little balsa wood
screens and stretched the thing
and then put the
decorative paper on the back.
And the minute I finished
putting the decorative paper
on the back, I realized that
it couldn't close [laughter],
emblematic of our
relationship [laughter].
Now one might think that
having made this structure
that didn't work that
you wouldn't choose it
as the structure for your first
book to make an edition of.
But you would be wrong.
And so, anyway, I came up
with this idea that I wanted
to make a book of Robinson
because although he has all
of this really gritty writing,
like, you know, boulders blunted
like bears' teeth, you know,
this thick masculine rating,
he also is extremely effusive
about sunsets and rainbows.
And his poetry is
populated by sort
of hard frontier
characters, but it's full
of remarkably sensitive
observations of nature
and people and motives and love.
And so, what I wanted to do
is I wanted to make a book
that was the exact opposite
of what one expected
of Robinson Jeffers.
And here it is.
So instead of a heavy
book, this is --
This can't weigh eight ounces.
I mean, it's just
incredibly light.
And so, there I was.
Okay. I'm going to
make this book.
And so, I get my
little font of type,
and I buy the kitakata
paper, and I print it.
And all the sudden,
I'm completely overcome
by crippling self-doubt.
And the sheets of paper sit
in my living room for months,
like, you know, albatross.
So like every time I looked at
them, they're like you failed,
you're not going to do it,
you're not going to do it.
And anyway, I finally got the
will to start making this.
And I go down to the
Center for Book Arts
and cut my little
pieces of balsa wood.
And the first four or five
copies, either the second
or third of the sixth panels was
either the wrong page or upside
down or completely misaligned.
I ruined -- It was if my doubt
just chose to sabotage me.
It was miserable.
I had this little coffee
table in front of my sofa
where I did all the
cutting and everything.
And my girlfriend's parents were
like, who the hell is this guy.
But anyway, I finally
finished one,
and I had no idea
what to do with it.
So I called the book dealer
Burton Weiss in California,
who was the only
book dealer I knew.
And I said, look,
I made this book.
Let me send one to you,
see what you can do,
and I need help deciding
what to price it.
And I thought maybe
$1500 or something.
And I sent it out to him, and he
calls me up and he's like, 475.
Like, well, okay.
And then he goes, and I
want the whole edition.
And I never forget this
feeling of hanging up the phone
and just thinking,
I'm going to be rich.
And, you know, all I've heard
about is Peter Koch complaining
about how hard it
is to sell books.
It's easy.
Well, the easy part of it
meant that over nine months,
I managed to make 14
copies that I got,
13 of them, I got $285 for.
You know, the paper on the
back cost $30 per copy.
There were two times when
I went into New York City,
bought the paper, and left it
on the train after I got off.
Like, I just -- Anyway, so.
[ Laughter ]
But what's amazing is that
this horrible process resulted
in two great things.
I published a book, which
got rid of an enormous amount
of fear of putting
myself out there.
And shortly after
selling a couple of copies
to Burton Weiss, I got a letter
from a man named Al Mears,
telling me how wonderful
he thought the book was,
and it was just this
transformative moment for me.
But so, it's also
this idea that the --
You know, printing is
such a practical art,
but here was an example of
making a decision about my work
that was so impractical,
but it led to this sort
of wonderful thing ultimately.
And I've just realized
that that's sort
of what I've continued to doing.
And so, I'm just
going to talk about --
I've got most of the books out
that I'm going to talk about.
A couple of years after making
"Meditation on Saviors,"
I was looking at this
woodcut by Francesco Clemente.
And I thought, God, it
looks like a watercolor.
And at the time, I was
living with a couple of guys,
one of whom was a theater
designer and he had a book
on the Commedia dell'arte,
about which I knew nothing.
But I started reading about
it, and I was fascinated
by this idea that the
characters were sort
of lived beyond the people
who actually played them.
They were stock characters who
were recognizable by their sort
of stock outfits and the
colors that they wore.
And I thought, wow, this would
be really fun to get a bunch
of magnesium cuts of
appropriated imagery
of these characters from
the Commedia dell'arte,
assign each a color, ink them in
watercolor paint, and print them
with paper that had standing
water on them and make it bleed
and be all this romantic,
sort of Commedia
dell'arte bleeding stuff.
And so, I ran out, and
I got one magnesium dye
and a tube of paint.
And I went to the Center for
Book Arts, and I rolled one up
and took a sheet of paper out of
a bath of water and carried it
over to a steel press, with
water just going everywhere,
and ran it through, and it
worked, and it was fantastic.
And so, I bought all this
paper; I bought all these cuts,
bought my watercolor paint.
And it turned out
that one print worked,
but it was a very,
very hot summer.
And the Center for Book Arts at
the time was 5000 square feet
with one little air-conditioner
window unit.
And it was so that I would roll
the watercolor onto the plate,
and by the time I got the
paper out of the bath and over,
it would have just dried enough.
And the water was so
wet that I'd print it,
and rather than the paint
going onto the paper,
the paper would stay
on the plate.
And so, I realized that what
I had to do was print it
in the middle of the night, when
it would be as cool as possible.
And so, I would get to the
center at one in the morning,
and I would get all the --
And some of these, you know,
because it was watercolor,
you had to print all the
colors in the same go.
And some of the pages, I
think the most is four colors
or five colors or
three or something.
And so, imagine you've
got your table,
you roll out the three colors,
you run over to the press, and,
you know, you're sort of holding
the brayers and going like that,
and then you get the paper,
run it through, go like that,
and then you have
to clean everything
because the paint has dried
on your brayers, on the glass,
on the plates and everything.
And it was just, you
know, one of those moments
where I did create this
book that was, you know,
it's got colors in it in a way
that I've never had
in a book before.
The prints are, you know,
looking back at them,
they're maybe not great.
But it was, again, this
moment of just like,
oh, well, it works once.
It's probably going to work
every time, or it doesn't work.
Maybe it'll work every time.
And a few months after that,
I was looking at this drawing
by Rudolf Koch with Fritz Kredel
when I was suddenly possessed
of the idea for a typeface
for the "Book of Job."
I had never designed
any kind of letter form.
I can't really draw, and
I'm not a calligrapher.
But I just was absolutely
convinced.
And I spent the night awake
in bed and, the next morning,
got out of bed and considered
myself a type designer.
And I really thought at the
time, this was December 1st,
1996, I really thought at
the time that, in 1997,
I would have a metal
type of my Job typeface
and I would print this
book to worldwide acclaim.
But since I didn't know how to
design type, I figured I have
to start by figuring out
how to draw letterforms.
And since I can't draw freehand
but I understand geometry,
I thought, well,
there's this tradition
of geometric letterforms,
and so I started drawing
and painting geometric letters.
And then I thought, well,
there's no way I can afford
to make a typeface, so how am I
going to raise the money for it.
And I know.
I'll raise the money
by making manuscripts
of geometric alphabets because
there's a huge market for that,
and I'll make tons of money,
and I'll make my typeface.
I don't think I need to tell
you how that turned out.
So I started doing
these manuscripts,
editioned manuscripts
where I would paint
and draw every letter of
the alphabet in every copy.
And although it never
led to making --
I didn't actually
make a typeface
until 2008, so 12 years later.
But what it initiated was it was
a completely crackpot moment.
I think I had pneumonia
at the time actually.
And yeah. And what
it ended up leading
to was this extended
study of letters as form,
and which seems simple,
but it's actually become --
Mark is holding up the a
from Eclectic Geometric
or Lunch with Nicolete.
This is the D and F and the P
and X. This is the last and,
by far, the most complex
geometric alphabet
that I've done.
The Library of Congress also
owns two unique alphabets
of this kind.
But, you know, so this
completely crackpot idea ended
up, you know, leading
to a study and work
that is the absolute foundation
of my entire career since then.
Every book of mine
deals with letterforms
in one way or another.
And it's gotten to the point
where I can't print my own words
in another person's typeface
without feeling like I'm lying.
So yeah. So that's a chapter.
And the other thing it did was
it completely tanked my printing
career from the time I started.
From 1998 until 2007, I didn't
publish any printed books,
except for a couple
of pamphlets.
And then just to bring us into
the contemporary era, in 2011,
I started -- So I designed
my first typeface in 2008.
By 2011, I had designed
quite a few typefaces,
and I have made a lot of books
about discrete letterforms,
alphabet books, and decided
that what I wanted to do was
to make a specimen
of my typefaces.
And while I was at the Codex
Book Fair, I was talking
to the representative of
the Velke Losiny Paper Mill
in the Czech Republic.
And he told me that for
under three dollars a sheet,
I could get a sheet of
handmade paper this big
with two custom watermarks
in it.
And I just thought this
is going to be great.
Give me a couple of sheets
that I can, you know,
test because I needed
3000 sheets for the book.
So I run home, and
I have these sheets
of paper, and do some tests.
And I notice, you know, the
type looks a little blacker
than usual, but I probably
just over inked it.
Yeah, I'll take the 3000 sheets.
And there they are, the
3000 sheets of paper coated
in such a thick coat
of gelatin sizing
that the reason the
letterforms looked thick is
because it was basically
plastic.
And when I printed
the ink on them,
instead of the ink being
absorbed into the paper,
it just went [splatter noise].
And so, well, that's easy.
Dampen the paper.
You know, everybody
in California has always
told me you draw one sheet
through about the
water, put five dry on,
one sheet through about
the water, five dry on,
leave it wrapped with
a little weight on it.
The next day, it's beautiful.
This is what it looked like
the next day, corrugated tin.
And so, but the problem was,
in order to get the
print quality I wanted,
I needed to dampen it,
which helps get some
of the gelatin sizing off of it.
But even if I found a way to
dampen it and get it smooth,
there was another problem,
that the paper stretched
three-eighths of an inch
across its width when it
was damp, which is enormous.
And just to give you
an idea of what kind
of printing I was planning on
doing, the tolerance of printing
in specimens of diverse
characters, which is the book,
is one two hundred
eighty-eighths of an inch.
The registration, that's the
registration, a quarter point.
So the gray lines in which those
two greens are printed is one
two hundred eighty-eighths
of an inch thick.
And just to show you
what the difference is,
this is three-eighths
of an inch,
and that's two hundred
eighty-eighths [laughter].
So basically, if the paper is
damp, the minute you take it
out of the humidor,
it starts shrinking
in all kinds of crazy ways.
And basically, unless I was
printing wood type posters,
there was no way
I could use this.
That was an unfair job.
One color, big prints.
There was no way I
could use this paper.
So what I realized is I
would have to dampen it
and dry before printing
it, which led to a bunch
of experiments of
how to dampen it
and dry it so it dried smooth.
We came up with loft drying,
just hanging it with clips.
The problem is, 3000
sheets of paper
in a 270 square foot studio
with two printing presses,
two people, two tables, a plate
maker, a guillotine cutter.
So what we had to do was
build lightweight drying racks
that could be lifted with paper
drying on it and put on tables,
and so twine and basswood.
This is Nancy stringing them up.
And Nancy Loeber and a
variety of other assistants,
mostly Sarah McDermott,
spent over 500 hours
that summer dampening and drying
paper just so I could print
on it, which was distressing.
This is my studio.
So, you know, so
I'm printing here.
This is my press.
I'm standing there.
There's paper drying.
There's paper drying there.
It was crazy.
It was just crazy.
But the book that resulted,
which is right there
on the table, it is the most
tactilely sensual book I've
ever made.
That paper, after --
Oh, I forgot to mention that at
a certain point in the process,
I realized that if I dampened
and dried each sheet
twice, it felt really good.
So that's what we did.
And so, you know, it
was this crazy summer.
I was not very enjoyable
for Annie I don't think.
But the --
>> So, if they hadn't
sized the paper,
would it have saved
you some work?
>> Russell Maret: Yes,
but it could have
caused other problems.
But we can deal with
that afterward.
But the other thing
-- So, you know,
it was completely worth
it, is what I'm saying,
for the book that ended up.
I love this book.
And it's the only book
I've ever made that feels
like that, which is great.
And then the other
thing that I did
for this book was I finally
made a metal type, you know,
14 years after 2007
when I was supposed
to have my metal Job typeface.
For this book, we ended up
making two metal typefaces.
And that's now a whole
other thing for me.
So I'm just going to do two
more short little things to show
that this is still going on.
For my book ornamental
digressions,
I design this 14-piece ornament
set that I had cast in metal,
and I wanted to do a
specimen book of it.
It was going to involve a lot
of color printing and a lot
of registration and
all of this stuff.
And again, each design
was inspired
by a text, a historical text.
And so, one of the
text is by D.R. Hay,
who was Queen Victoria's
interior decorator,
and he wrote a book called "The
Laws of Harmonious Colouring,"
which is such a Victorian title.
And in it is this wonderful
illustration, which I wanted
to try to re-create in the book.
And now, when I'm doing
complex color printing,
I always proof all the way
through to make sure
all the colors work,
everything works together.
But with this print, I realized
it was going to be 16 colors,
and I just couldn't bear it.
I knew it was going to work.
It was definitely going to work.
So I just didn't proof it,
and I just printed the thing
and ended up with this.
And immediately,
said, well, I can't.
This is so ugly.
It's an upside down shield
with like a radioactive
sign in the middle.
And the reason is, is because
this whole design is predicated
on 60-degree angles,
and my ornaments work
on 45-degree angles.
And so, it just doesn't work.
The text is no perfectly
harmonious arrangement
of colors can be made unless
all the three primary colors be
present, which I
actually agree with.
Cezanne was the great
proof of this.
Every color of his had
all three colors in it.
So anyway, so I didn't like
this, and so I decide, okay,
I'll design a different print
that only nine press runs.
And whereas this one had
the primary, secondary,
and tertiary colors, this one
just had primary and secondary.
And although it's a
bit rainbowy, you know,
you love having a
spectrum in a color book.
And while I'm printing books
like this, I keep all the prints
out on a table to just
sort of get a sense
of what everything is like.
And one day, Nancy
Loeber was in the studio.
And she came over, and
she had her cup of coffee,
and she's just sort of looking.
And she puts her finger
right here and just says,
doesn't harmonious have two o's.
And so, I had printed a 16 press
run and a nine press run print
with 10 words, one of
which was misspelled,
which ended up in me making
this final four press run print,
which is by far the best image.
It only uses the
three primary colors.
You clearly see, when you
look at it closely at least,
how they modify each other.
And all of the other ones
had all this extraneous stuff
that wasn't necessary.
It just took like, you know,
three weeks of printing
and a case of raging
plantar fasciitis
to figure it out, you know.
It was like -- And, okay.
The last one is a book
I'm currently working on,
just a little thing.
I don't have anything of that
because it's at the binders now.
But for these book
character traits
that I just finished printing,
the book is about
digital letterforms,
and it explores the idea
that digital letterforms
are not typographic.
They have nothing
technologically in common
with typographic
letterforms, meaning metal type.
And so, I wanted to make a book
where I designed lettering free
from the presumptions of what
typographic technology would
make you make letters for.
And because of that,
I decided, oh, well,
I shouldn't print
the letterforms
on a typographic press.
I should print them as etchings.
And I've only printed
two etchings before,
but I'm sure I can do it.
And what's even better is
that by taking the plates
and inking the intaglio
lines and wiping the surface,
I can then roll a second
color onto the relief surface
and get these two colors
printed super vibrantly
at the same time, and
it'll be really cool.
And it is cool, until
I tried printing it
and realized that
what that meant.
It had never occurred to me
that I would then have to clean
between every print,
totally clean
with solvent the intolerable
lines and the surface
and let it dry, or else the
colors would contaminate
each other.
And you'd only get
one good print.
And so, this is the
inking, the intaglio wiping,
the intaglio rolling up, dousing
solvent, scrubbing with a brush,
and waiting for the plate
to dry, which meant that,
at their worst, these prints
could take 30 minutes each
to make.
And to give you an idea,
for the whole edition,
there were 2375 etchings
to be printed,
which I'm now really
good at printing.
And so, the solution was
that the deluxe copies
of the book have more
two-color prints in them
than the standard
copies of the book.
So it allowed me to
do what I wanted to do
but in a more limited way.
And the standard copies still
have some two-color prints.
But, you know, all of
these examples are things
that if you -- You know, Annie
and I have this joke where she,
you know, asks me how it
went in the studio today.
And I'll say, well,
I learned a lot.
That's when I'm in a good mood.
So at the time, these
feel kind of like torture,
each one of these things.
But without them, I would just
be doing the same thing over
and over again, which I
have no tolerance to do.
And so, it's actually, you know,
even though every
time it happens,
I say next time it's
going to be better,
it's actually the
only thing that has
to get better is my sort
of living with the fact
that things are going
to go horribly wrong.
And so, to end, I love this
because I'm going to quote
from a publication that,
according to its publication
date, doesn't yet exist.
The January 21st edition
of the New Yorker.
There was just this
perfect quote to end
from an article called Choose
Wisely by Joshua Rothman talking
about the philosopher
Agnes Callard.
He says, when we're aspiring,
inarticulateness isn't a sign
of unreasonableness
or incapacity.
In fact, the opposite
may be true.
"Everyone goes to college
to become educated,"
Callard observes, "but
until I am educated,
I do not really know
what an education is
or why it is important."
If we couldn't aspire to changes
that we struggle to describe,
we'd be trapped within the
ideas that we already have.
Our inability to explain
our reasons is a measure
of how far we wish to travel.
It's only after an aspirant
has reached her destination,
Callard writes, that "she
will say, "This is why.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: We have a
little bit of time for questions
if people would like to.
>> What's next?
>> Russell Maret:
It's a big secret.
No. I'm working on a --
I have a lot of ideas.
But I'm editing a book of
writing by Sandra Kirshenbaum,
who is the editor of
Fine Print Magazine.
That's going to be
published by the Book Club
of California this fall.
I'm putting together a group
of essays of mine into a book
for publication by someone else.
But that won't be ready
probably to submit
until the end of the year.
And yeah, and a couple
other things.
I'm really enjoying
this experimenting
with the differences
between typographic
and non-typographic letters.
But one of the things that
character traits taught me was
that -- You know, I draw these
kind of crazy letterforms,
you know, that verge
on abstraction,
and then I print
them individually.
But then when I print texts,
I design pretty traditional
looking typefaces.
And I've always wanted those
qualities to merge in some way.
But what character traits taught
me was that in order to do that,
the content of my
books needs to change.
My texts that I typically set
in my traditional
typefaces is usually notes
or an addendum to
some other work.
And so, I'm trying to
figure out what that means,
that somehow I need to start
working with texts that allow me
to experiment more
visually with words,
rather than having
them separate.
So I've got a couple ideas
of texts that I would
like to explore that with.
But I've got a lot to
do in the meantime.
Yeah. Yeah?
>> In "Specimens of
Diverse Characters,"
can you talk a little bit
about your [inaudible]
and plate making to kind of
achieve some of the [inaudible]?
>> Russell Maret: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So in the book "Specimens
of Diverse Characters,"
except for those two typefaces
and some metal ornaments,
everything is printed
from photopolymer plates,
which is primarily what I print
from because I design my
typefaces and letterforms
on the computer and I
output a film negative,
a laser film negative,
and then expose it
to a photopolymer plate that
makes a raised printing surface.
And in that book, there
are a number of prints.
When you think of a
letterpress, you typically think
of line and void, you know.
It's either a solid printing
or there's no printing.
But in this book, there's
a lot of overprinting
of subtle gradations of
color and tone that were made
by me just doing pencil
drawings on tracing paper
and scanning them and outputting
them as halftone film.
So I think those are the marks
you're talking about, yeah.
Some of them are quite precise,
but some of them are really just
me making a field of graphite
and then scanning it
and using it as texture.
But it's really wonderful
because, you know,
when you print one dot
halftone plate, it looks dotty.
It looks like it's
a bunch of dots.
When you print a second
different one on top of it,
it starts to look more
like continuous tone.
And so, all of the sort of
gradations of color that you see
in that book are achieved
by printing at least two
and often four to six plates of
halftones on top of each other.
And so, there's still a little
bit of dottiness, but, you know,
from this distance, it's
convincing, you know.
Yeah. Yeah.
Anyone else?
Yes?
>> Yeah. So continuing on with
your use of computer or design,
have you gotten into working
with 3D at all on the computer,
3D capabilities, not to print
something in 3D, but actually
to manipulate forms
in 3D on the screen?
>> Russell Maret: You know, no,
not because I'm opposed to it.
I'm one of those
people who works a lot
on the computer and
doesn't like it.
So I haven't been
very adventurous
in learning what the computer
can do beyond drawing outlines,
which is what I like
to do on the computer.
The outline gives me the form.
And I haven't even in
my book character traits
where I'm experimenting
with digital letterforms.
Most millennials would
think that what I came
up with was quite
conservative, I think.
They still look pretty much
like letterforms, you know.
And so, I haven't
really gone deeply
into what something
that's just going to exist
in digital space can be.
But I like seeing it.
It's just that I really,
you know, drawing letters
on the computer, even
though I do it all the time,
is just excruciating.
It's so, you know, just
dot and pull it a little.
And it's just horrible.
So by the time I'm done with
the day, all I want to do is
like feel some oil on my
hands, you know, or something
and go to my print shop.
So it's kind of nice
that I get to split that.
But yeah, no.
Yeah?
>> I have the good fortune,
we have the good fortune
of sitting near eclectic
geometric
and there's power
emanating off these things.
Can you talk about
the black hole?
Can you talk about the
technique and how [inaudible]?
>> Russell Maret: Yeah, yeah.
Each one of those, the drawings
are in pencil liquid watercolor.
Well, this one's just India ink
and then painted
in black gouache.
And that's what the black
is, which is that wonderful,
nonreflective, yeah, yeah.
And even on the sort
of softer white paper
of eclectic geometric, it's
still -- And I love that,
that quality of the black.
>> India ink and gouache.
>> Russell Maret: So the way
it's done is every line is
either pencil, the blue
is liquid watercolor,
and then the black
lines and the outline
of the letters are India ink and
then basically then just painted
in the lines with black gouache.
>> Edition of how many?
>> Russell Maret: Ten.
Started in 2001.
I painted the last
one in 2008 I think.
And actually, Nancy Loeber
painted about half of them.
I did all the drawing, but that
was the first thing she worked
for me on was painting
some of those.
>> They're elegant and powerful.
>> Russell Maret: Thanks.
Thank you.
Yeah?
>> Are you familiar with
vantablack, which is --
>> Russell Maret:
Oh, it's the --
>> It's like 99.9 --
>> Russell Maret:
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah,
that what's his name owns.
Yeah, Anish Kapoor owns.
Yeah, yeah.
I've still never seen it.
But the --
>> It'd be interesting to
have a print using that.
It takes a special lab to do it.
>> Russell Maret: Well, yeah.
And he owns the color period.
There's no Russell
getting to use vantablack.
So, but he's -- Yeah.
>> You don't need it.
You don't need it
>> Russell Maret:
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
But I love Anish Kapoor's
work, and I have felt
that in recent years, it's
gotten a little too glossy.
And so, it'll be really
fun to see what he does
with something you
can't see actually.
I mean, that's what's
so amazing about it.
It's just an absence of
light, which is incredible.
But yeah, it's for him to
play with and me to admire.
>> Mark Dimunation: I
think we'll stop there.
Before we thank Russell, if
the people sitting on benches
in front of the table can get
up and push the benches in,
people can come and
look at books.
We'll be happy to show you
whatever you like to see.
Keep in mind that some of
these books don't belong to us.
So we're asking you to
be extra mindful today.
But we're happy --
>> Russell Maret: But
not to touch them.
>> Mark Dimunation:
Yeah, just not touch.
But we'll be happy to
show you whatever we can.
And let's thank Russell
for a great job.
[ Applause ]